ce qu'on ne sait pas par exemple c'est
qu'au bout de l'île de nantes via les
quais on les doit aux américains
lesquels que l'on voit encore
actuellement ses quais entre là c'est la
poutrelle de béton entrelacés sont en
fait des quais pour l'essentiel
américain et puis dernière chose le
département a eu lieu donc un petit
siège de 25 juin le 26 juin 1910 f
est-ce que ça a été un tournant alors ça
a été un tournant sera pas à pas
immédiatement mais à terme c'est un
tournoi extrêmement important niveau
stratégique dans la mesure où
effectivement donc ça permet à l'armée
française comme dit pétain d'attendre
les chars et les américains de relancer
effectivement l'aspect militaire je
reviens de nick 72 merci
le muc 72 le club de football qui y
vivent je vous laisse découvrir le
reportage de fourmies et d'aline de la
sorcellerie
[Musique]